[Música]
ah
son tal vez las elecciones
presidenciales con el mayor grado de
polarización e incertidumbre sobre el
futuro que pueda enfrentar colombia este
país suramericano se debate entre darle
continuidad a los gobiernos de tendencia
de derecha o dar un viraje y por primera
vez dar la oportunidad a un presidente
de izquierda colombia es un escenario
muy particular para un proceso electoral
democrático hay señalamientos a las
autoridades electorales después de los
resultados de las elecciones
parlamentarias la violencia por parte de
las disidencias también los grupos
guerrilleros que se mantienen y los
grupos armados ligados al narcotráfico
han repuntado y también el descontento y
el reclamo social que llevó a ese
estallido social que todavía está en la
memoria de los colombianos a esto
también hay que sumar un crecimiento
económico lento alta inflación y un
digamos
desvanecimiento de colombia' en el
liderazgo regional y en el escenario
mundial pero quienes son los que se
están disputando la silla en el palacio
de nariño veamos entonces en la gráfica
quienes son por lo menos los que mayor
concentración de intención de voto tiene
de acuerdo a las últimas encuestas
gustavo petro es el candidato de la
coalición al pacto histórico que reúne a
la izquierda colombiana sergio fajardo
de la coalición centro esperanza también
participa rodolfo hernández de la liga
gobernantes ante corrupción y federico
gutiérrez de la coalición equipo por
colombia que representan como lo decía
los candidatos con la mayor intención de
votos de acuerdo con las encuestas
recientes también hay otros candidatos
como john milton rodríguez y enrique
gómez
no es simple el escenario al que se
enfrentan los colombianos está mucho en
juego y por eso hoy analizamos el
panorama de colombia de cara a esa
primera ronda de las elecciones
presidenciales en colombia para analizar
este tema saludamos a berlín singer ella
es profesora de la facultad de estudios
internacionales políticos y urbanos de
la universidad rosario de la ciudad de
bogotá también es columnista del diario
'el espectador' allí en colombia por
supuesto se encuentra en la ciudad de
bogotá en la capital colombiana y aquí
en el estudio de france 24 nos acompaña
patricia muñoz ella es directora de
postgrados en ciencia política de la
facultad de ciencia política y
relaciones internacionales patricios
temas recuerda la universidad pontificia
universidad javeriana de la pontificia
universidad javeriana que por supuesto
está también ubicada en la ciudad de
bogotá ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con todos los comentarios y preguntas
que deseen hacer lo pueden hacer a
través de las redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram
también en twitter estamos como france24
bajo ese mi cuenta personal santi logo y
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos y sus preguntas
comienzo entonces por darle la
bienvenida a darling bienvenida al
programar link un gusto saludarla como
siempre y quiero comenzar como punto de
partida del debate que construyamos un
panorama general de lo que está
sucediendo en colombia el marco general
en el que se van a desarrollar estas
elecciones presidenciales bienvenida a
rim y muchas gracias santiago y buenas
noches y aprovecho para saludar a mi
colega patricia también yo creo que hay
varios elementos que hay que tener de
presente para tener claro el panorama en
el cual estas elecciones se dan el
primer factor es el que santiago ya sean
al ascenso introducción un contexto
generalizado de descontento de
indignación de tristeza dependiendo de
quien preguntamos en torno a un conjunto
de agravios sociales económicos y
políticos que han generado un contexto
electoral muy distinto al que hemos
observado en años anteriores en colombia
y cuyo digamos antesala inmediata son
las estas sociales que han aparecido en
el contexto nacional desde 2019 creo que
un segundo factor tiene que ver con la
profunda polarización que existe en
torno a esta contienda presidencial si
bien en las elecciones pasadas hace
cuatro años con el ascenso de gustavo
petro y su paso a segunda vuelta
podríamos decir que hubo también
polarización pero antes su función en
las encuestas que ha sido algo
permanente desde el año pasado y sus
posibilidades ahora sí reales de llegar
a ser presidente de colombia yo creo que
el grado de polarización el grado de
agresividad e incluso entre distintas
campañas y al vídeo de la sociedad
colombiana han aumentado
y también le doy la bienvenida entonces
a patricia que en el estudio de france24
patricia gracias por acompañarnos su
panorama el escenario de colombia para
estas elecciones gracias santiago un
caluroso saludo arlín y complementando
este escenario que are línea inició tres
consultas previas que participaron 15
candidatos en total y que permitió dar
un inicio de campaña intenso no habíamos
tenido antes consultas con tan alto
número de candidatos unas elecciones al
congreso de la república realizadas el
pasado 13 de marzo y que mostraron un
repunte de la izquierda en el número de
curules tanto en senado como en cámara
sin lograr una mayoría que le permita al
candidato de izquierda en caso de ganar
la contienda presidencial poder sacar
adelante por sí solo estas
iniciativas de gobierno sin que tenga
que armar coaliciones al interior del
congreso
la expectativa frente a la posibilidad
de que un candidato diferente a este
sector de derecha que usted ha
mencionado santiago pueda ocupar por
primera vez la la silla presidencial y
un ambiente marcado por el alejamiento
de posiciones esto de la polarización y
por supuesto de demanda por parte de los
ciudadanos en torno a la profundización
de propuestas por los candidatos
patricia continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa en los colombianos
están enfrentando un similar escenario
similar de izquierda a derecha y que tan
conformes están los colombianos con
tener que volver a elegir entre un lado
o el otro o cómo está ese espectro
político fíjate santiago que en el 2014
y el 2018 las elecciones presidenciales
estuvieron marcadas por el tema de la
paz en el 2014 por la aprobación de este
acuerdo de paz por la firma primero del
acuerdo de paz y en el 2018 por la
refrendación de esta firma a través del
plebiscito que posteriormente permite
que gane el no sobre el fin acentuando
estas lejanías y estas diferencias sin
embargo el escenario de 2022 precedido
por estas protestas marchas demandas de
los ciudadanos por mayores oportunidades
de empleo y acceso a la educación
liderada por jóvenes que reclaman una
serie de
logros de cumplimiento de promesas por
parte del gobierno se ve marcada por
estos temas económicos recuperación post
pandemia y todo este proceso de
reclamación social
que ya nos marca una primera diferencia
con relación a la contienda anterior y
este escenario de polarización que
habíamos visto que parecía que se
marcaba aún más después de las consultas
entre el candidato de izquierda y y el
de derecha
entra a un proceso diferente con la
participación de un candidato
independiente que de acuerdo a los
estudios de opinión
parece estar movilizando un buen
porcentaje de electores un candidato del
que te vamos a hablar más adelante
quiero preguntarle al link sobre sobre
esta esta dualidad a la que vuelven a
enfrentarse los colombianos de izquierda
a derecha blanco o negro están conformes
los colombianos con tener que volver a
escoger entre lo mismo se habla mucho de
continuismo se habla de dar oportunidad
a un cambio pero es un cambio que da una
buena porción de la ciudadanía no le
convence tampoco
pues yo creo que hay que comenzar
afirmando que en términos generales la
población colombiana desconfía
profundamente de las instituciones
políticas del país de los partidos
políticos y en general tristemente de la
democracia fenómeno que estamos
observando no sólo aquí sí sino en
américa latina y en el mundo en general
y esto evidentemente predispone a los
electores a no entusiasmarse
necesariamente con ningún candidato y
abstener pues en otros casos de
participar en procesos electorales
colombia tiene una de las alzas de
abstención más altas de nuestra región
por no hablar del mundo y creo que esto
es un contexto importante que tener de
presente cuando hablamos de que tan afín
y que tanta afinidad tienen los
electores con estos dos polos y ahora
bien es cierto que estamos viviendo
una repetición de cierta manera al menos
de
posibilidades de candidatos de centro el
perdón de izquierda de derecha
en comparación con las elecciones
pasadas la gran diferencia es que ponte
a la inversa el candidato de izquierda a
gustavo petro y el del continuismo
representado por federico gutiérrez pues
enfrenta una batalla difícil yo creo en
términos de poder ganar si logra pasar a
la segunda vuelta creo que algo que a mí
me llama la atención en estas elecciones
pensando en estos dos espectros
ideológicos es la imposibilidad que ha
tenido el centro de puntear de manera
efectiva en las impuestas y en la
contienda presidencial hubo una colisión
de centro que yo creo que aspiraba a
poder ocupar justamente este espacio
intermedio y por diversos motivos la
candidatura de sergio fajardo pues
simplemente no o despegar y un contexto
en el que nuevamente habríamos esperado
que el centro fuera una opción que el
lectores
no identificados con los dos extremos
pudieran haber escogido
que dice patricia sobre esto que
menciona arlín de ese espectro del
centro que se vino desvaneciendo
conforme pasaron las semanas perdió
fuerza dentro de la intención de voto y
precisamente no logró reunir a todas
esas personas que no quieren tener que
elegir entre el habitual blanco negro
izquierda derecha y no se fueron por el
centro porque él fue el centro nunca
logró construir una buena base electoral
santiago el centro vivió una serie de
desencuentros internos tensiones
dificultades para poder establecer
algunas reglas de juego comunes
aceptadas por todos
diferencias que trascendieron a la
opinión pública y que primero sembraron
de esta sensación de que el centro es
esa
a ese espacio ideológico y esas
candidaturas llamadas a recoger un alto
nivel de inconformidad con las
candidaturas existentes y sobre todo con
las candidaturas de los extremos que ese
centro 2 luego de esas dificultades
internas no era la mejor opción para
poder gobernar de hecho sergio fajardo
tuvo un desempeño electoral muy inferior
al que se esperaba
en las disputas por las tres coaliciones
la de izquierda la de centro y la de
derecha ahora bien es claro que hay una
hay un sentimiento de inconformidad hay
un sentimiento de malestar en los
ciudadanos colombianos no diferentes a
muchos del malestar que se vive en los
países de la región frente al desempeño
de las instituciones de los gobernantes
de los actores políticos y de la
política que también ha generado esa esa
sensación de desapego falta de
participación y falta de respaldo a los
procesos electorales que se están
viviendo el centro vive entonces esta
atención que logra un resultado
inferior al esperado y luego una
candidatura independiente que logra
conectarse quizás mejor desde el punto
de vista comunicativo
empleando un lenguaje sencillo directo
apropiándose de un tema especial como es
el de la lucha contra la corrupción
lograr reducir aún más las posibilidades
del centro además un desempeño del
centro muy débil comparado con hace
cuatro años cuando sergio fajardo fue la
tercera fuerza política más votada y fue
prácticamente decisivo a dónde iban a ir
sus votantes para la segunda vuelta fue
una gran controversia en colombia en ese
momento en este en este caso el
escenario es muy diferente ustedes dos
mencionan la institucionalidad
yo lo mencionaba la introducción del
programa esas críticas que hay a la
registraduría nacional del estado civil
que es el ente electoral encargado de
organizar logísticamente las elecciones
en colombia y hay muchas críticas
después de las elecciones parlamentarias
de hace unos meses atrás también estamos
hablando de un país que le cuesta mucho
tener presencia en las regiones y es uno
de los puntos de origen de la situación
social en colombia arleen se puede
confiar en este proceso electoral hay
garantías que hasta el último rincón de
colombia puedan llegar las papeletas
para votar haya seguridad y se puede
confiar en la institucionalidad
pues yo creo que a modo de hipótesis
general
las instituciones electorales en
colombia han demostrado ser confiables y
transparentes
desafortunadamente en las elecciones
legislativas de marzo esta tendencia se
trastocó con las diferencias
significativas entre los votos en el
preconteo y la la finalización y
oficialización de la votación lo cual
evidentemente ha arrojado dudas y
sospechas adicionales entre los
electores que han sido también
aprovechados por básicamente todos los
los candidatos y las campañas que sin
importar quién gane yo creo que van a
gritar fraude y van a ahondar
en la falta de credibilidad
del proceso electoral ahora bien no es
claro para mí al menos que esas dudas
significa necesariamente que nuestro
proceso electoral no esté brindado y no
vaya a arrojar unos resultados limpios y
creo que en este sentido en estas
elecciones la presencia de observadores
internacionales que a modo anecdotal
siento que son mayores que en elecciones
pasadas se va a jugar un rol muy muy
importante justamente en distintos
rincones del país a la hora de apoyar y
reforzar la credibilidad de los
resultados yo le doy la palabra patricia
quiero preguntarle a alguien sobre este
estas críticas que hicieron los
diferentes candidatos y sus coaliciones
después de las parlamentarias
empezaron a sembrar un poco de manto de
duda entre la ciudadanía esto tiene
algún componente político se estarían
jugando ahí una carta previendo el
escenario
la segunda vuelta
esta primera y única vuelta presidencial
y era simplemente una estrategia
allanando hay un poco el terreno
en parte sí y de nuevo la tendencia a
acusar de fraude ya es un fenómeno
generalizado en las democracias en el
mundo tristemente pero por otro lado en
el caso del pacto histórico
efectivamente las denuncias de los
problemas en el preconteo arrojaron unas
diferencias de varios cientos de miles
de votos en la oficialización del voto
lo cual sí constata un problema si se
quiere técnico en el diseño de los
formatos de tabulación que arrojó un
resultado inicial que no fue el
definitivo patricia algo que decir al
respecto por supuesto
con la registraduría este
año en este proceso electoral que
vivimos el 13 de marzo
hubo cuestionamientos en torno a algunas
decisiones decisiones frente a la
construcción y el diseño de los
tarjetones electorales
decisiones con relación a los jurados
que se iban a designar por mesas y las
bases para designar estos jurados ellos
para decir que muchos de los anuncios de
fraude que
obedecen en buena parte a este
nerviosismo político que obedecen en
buena parte a estos a esta forma de
buscar e internos
intervenir en la contienda electoral
sin embargo luego se descubrió se
comprobó que todos los procesos habían
sido errores había habido errores en
diseños había habido errores en las
decisiones políticas y todo ello y ha
sido corregido creo para este proceso
que vamos a vivir ahora el 29 de mayo
había sido importante la presencia de la
observación internacional pero también
en la intervención de organizaciones
nacionales las voces que se levantaron
de la ciudadanía
las voces que se escucharon de muchos
actores políticos primero llamando la
calma para preservar la pureza del
proceso electoral y segundo haciendo un
llamado a la autoridad electoral para
que esta limpieza que ha sido
característica de los procesos
electorales en colombia
se mantenga y preocupa que no vaya a
haber una auditoría internacional
patricia
correcto y se discutió mucho las últimas
semanas en torno a la auditoría pero los
tiempos no jugaban a favor
pero los procesos también para que una
auditoría entrara a pocos días a pocas
semanas en menos casi de una semana ya
recomendaban que era mejor no hacerlo en
estos momentos hay un acuerdo en que hay
algunos sistemas de auditoría
allí creados que van a funcionar y que
de parte de la ciudadanía y de las
organizaciones nacionales e
internacionales va a haber un
acompañamiento a través de la
observación y de la vez hablemos un poco
en profundidad de los candidatos gustavo
petro ya lo decía yo es quien encabeza
esta coalición que representa a los
partidos de izquierda de acuerdo a los
últimos sondeos no voy a decir números
pero ha liderado desde hace varias
semanas esos indicadores de preferencia
de voto es un personaje muy
controvertido dentro de la historia
política colombiana pero ha estado
presente desde hace ya varias varios
años en el escenario como senador como
candidato presidencial en otras en otras
elecciones y también fue alcalde de
bogotá que se puede decir de él arleen
que se puede hablar de este personaje
que podría llegar a ser en ningún
escenario el que lleve a colombia a un
gobierno de izquierda por primera vez en
su historia
pues sería difícil resumir en pocos en
pocos minutos un retrato fidedigno de
cualquiera de los candidatos pero creo
que quisiera destacar que se trata de un
candidato que como bien señala santiago
ha estado en estado dedicado a la vida
política al servicio público desde hace
muchos años algo que lo ha caracterizado
en su paso largo por el congreso ha sido
el liderazgo de las denuncias frente a
la parapolítica y el rol del
paramilitarismo en nuestro país algo que
creo que distintos sectores le reconocen
en su paso por la alcaldía de bogotá
veo que hay lecturas encontradas sobre
los resultados que obtuvo por un lado
hay críticas de su estilo de liderazgo y
de administrador más que todo en el
ejercicio de la alcaldía pero al mismo
tiempo hay que reconocer que justamente
por el carácter controversial rodeado en
estos años enfrentó mucha oposición y
muchos obstáculos a la hora de tratar de
implementar su agente de gobierno desde
la alcaldía de bogotá creo que en esta
contienda electoral es algo que no
observamos en las elecciones pasadas es
el éxito con el cual el rodeado de otros
actores políticos de izquierda han
logrado mantener la diferencia de
contiendas previas una una alianza muy
diversa llena de posiciones creo que
diferentes en términos ideológicos
políticos sociales que ha llevado a un
triunfo significativo en las elecciones
legislativas y que podrá
efectivamente llevarlo a ganar la
presidencia con una plataforma del
cambio creo que genuino y atención a los
distintos agravios sociales y económicos
que han manifestado los colombianos y
las colombianas en estos últimos años
a petro se le ve como un candidato muy
controvertido ya lo decía yo con una
ciudad muy progresistas muchas
representan esos ideales de cambio que
tienen muchas de las nuevas generaciones
que van a votar en estas en estas
elecciones pero también se les señala de
dividir mucho y de ser uno de los
artífices en buena parte de la
polarización que vive colombia y esa
separación de representar esos
resentimientos sociales que ha
caracterizado a la sociedad colombiana
como lo ve usted si santiago gustavo
petro a lo largo de su carrera política
y en los diferentes espacios que ha
ocupado tanto en el congreso de la
república las campañas a presidencia
y alcaldía y luego su paso por la
alcaldía de bogotá ha sido un candidato
que genera
controversia y que algunas de sus
posiciones
son vistas como de extremos que
polarizan el escenario de campaña ha
gustado petro incluso cuando en los
estudios de opinión pública se le miden
sus niveles de desfavorabilidad estos
han sido altos históricamente pero hay
que decir algo santiago gustavo petro
2022 consciente quizás de estos procesos
que generaron polarización en el pasado
realiza una campaña de mayor apertura a
diferentes voces y fuerzas ideológicas
bautiza su pacto como pacto histórico
precisamente para abrir la inclusión de
diferentes
alternativas fuerzas diferentes grupos
étnicos género también allí había
representación en el pacto histórico
se ha rodeado de actores políticos
algunos de ellos tradicionales que le ha
merecido cuestionamiento por supuesto
sobre todo de mí desde el sector de la
izquierda pero ha buscado brindar un a
construir una imagen de una mayor
apertura de inclusión y de posibilidades
de trabajo con diferentes sectores lo
cual también ha hecho reducir en parte
esos niveles de
oposición que algunos le plantean solo
por el hecho de ser buscado y también
incluso llegó con un discurso un poco
más moderado si lo comparamos con la
campaña
quienes pueden ser clave para llevar a
la izquierda un triunfo en colombia
patricia los jóvenes las minorías los
indígenas las zonas rurales la
concentración colombia es un país de
grandes ciudades más que zonas rurales
quienes pueden ser clave para llevar a
la izquierda al triunfo yo creo en
santiago que
de los diferentes sectores de los
diferentes grupos poblacionales que
intervienen en el proceso al primero una
importancia especial para los llamados
independientes votos de opinión ese
sector que habita generalmente en
centros urbanos en ese votante menos
apegado a los partidos políticos
tradicionales que puede ver en la
izquierda una opción de recoger
inconformidad por supuesto hay que
sumarle allí las bases militantes de los
partidos y movimientos de izquierda que
ha ido aumentando y si miramos por
sectores de población
los jóvenes han sido más cercanos
tradicionalmente a apoyar la izquierda
sin embargo hoy si miramos los estudios
de opinión el desempeño de gustavo petro
en los diferentes grupos en las
diferentes regiones en los diferentes de
sectores poblacionales estratos
socioeconómicos
es un buen desempeño superior al de la
mayoría de los candidatos
regiones por ejemplo solo federico
gutiérrez
obtiene mayor movilización en la zona
cafetera antioquia y rodolfo hernández
en la zona de los santanderes pero la
presencia de petro en términos
regionales y el apoyo en votos es
bastante nacional bastante nacional y
llamamos un poco más allá de la meta del
programa voy a acelerar un poco alguien
quiero que hablemos de federico
gutiérrez otro de los candidatos el dice
que no se identifica de un lado del otro
él se identifica como un candidato de
unión que tiene algunas cosas de centro
algunos componentes de la derecha otros
lo ven como el candidato del
expresidente uribe unos lo ven como la
continuidad de lo que ha vivido colombia
en los últimos cuatro años con el
presidente duque como lo ve usted a
federico gutiérrez
pues yo sí lo veo como el candidato del
continuismo
desde su alcaldía de medellín ha buscado
proyectarse como un candidato
independiente pero en realidad desde la
alcaldía de medellín es claro al menos
para mí y para quienes son expertos en
el tema que es y ha sido el elegido de
álvaro uribe entonces creo que es
difícil eludir este hecho al tratar de
analizar su candidatura presidencial
entonces creo que en un momento como el
actual que hemos descrito como cambiante
en el cual ya no está en el centro del
debate político la cuestión de la guerra
o la paz y la consolidación de los
acuerdos de paz sino el cambio que ha
tenido que manejar un discurso o un acto
de balanceo muy complejo en el sentido
de que al mismo tiempo que tiene que
hacer gestos hacia la derecha y hacia el
establecimiento político si se quiere de
derecha tiene que también proyectarse
como alguien independiente que promete
cambio y creo que esa dificultad es lo
que explica por un lado porque eso sus
encuestas se han estancado por otro lado
es un candidato que hasta el forma
similar a rodolfo hernández no tiene
mucha experiencia en la política tal vez
no era el candidato para que la derecha
lanzara en este momento sino en unos
años y creo que esta falta de
experiencia y falta de conectarte de
conocimiento que al lado de un gustavo
petro o de un sergio fajardo se vuelve
muy palpable en los debates en algo que
puede estar calando también
negativamente
frente a sus posibilidades de llegar a
la presidencia de nuevo si es que pasa a
la segunda una la segunda vuelta me
llama la atención que es un país que
pide cambio que las campañas estuvieron
en torno al cambio pero los problemas de
siempre en ese país permanecen vigentes
no se han solucionado los problemas de
la violencia la inseguridad el
narcotráfico los grupos guerrilleros y
se está hablando de cambio cuando ni
siquiera ha habido un amplio avance en
los acuerdos de paz eso solo como para
hacerla la anotación rodolfo hernández
patricia un cambio independiente un
ingeniero que fue alcalde de una ciudad
intermedia en la ciudad de bucaramanga
ha venido escalando rápidamente no
representa ninguno de los partidos
habituales tradicionales ni estas
grandes coaliciones y va con un discurso
anti corrupción quién es este personaje
que irrumpió en la escena de la política
colombiana inesperadamente usted lo ha
dicho santiago fue alcalde de la ciudad
de bucaramanga una ciudad intermedia en
el país es el candidato mayor de la
contienda y sin embargo con su discurso
con su estrategia comunicativa no sólo
de manera directa y personal sino a
través de las redes ha logrado cautivar
a un buen número de votantes
rodolfo hernández se ha apropiado de ese
malestar principal que los colombianos
manifiestan contra la corrupción y esa
es a ese discurso anti corrupción contra
la clase política contra los actores
políticos contra los electos
popularmente que no cumplan cumple lo
ofrecido le ha generado un punto de
conexión con los electores y ese punto
de conexión ese vínculo ha logrado
gracias a su acierto en la forma de
comunicar
directa empleando un lenguaje sencillo y
empleando incluso
expresiones populares que lo hacen
identificar fácilmente con los
ciudadanos lo colocan como la persona
que podría resolver ese tema que molesta
especialmente que es el tema asociado a
la corrupción
ese rodolfo hernández y su ascenso en la
intención de voto ha reducido las
posibilidades del candidato de centro
sergio fajardo y los últimos estudios de
opinión incluso muestran un empate
técnico con el candidato federico
gutiérrez y la posibilidad incluso de
pasar a un acción a segunda vuelta es
como el sergio fajardo de las elecciones
pasadas que fue el tercero y fue captar
la atención de la opinión pública
rodolfo hernández es muy comentado en
últimas semanas en colombia su opinión
arlín sobre este candidato independiente
y yo lo resumiría de la siguiente manera
yo veo a hernández como una combinación
de trump bolsonaro bukle y del salvador
y duterte de filipinas en el sentido de
que es en efecto un candidato populista
cuyo discurso sencillo anti
establecimiento anticorrupción ha
cautivado a electores
en diferentes partes del país no solo en
la zona de bucaramanga y sus alrededores
me preocupa de eso de su campaña lo que
podríamos llamar la vaciedad de sus
propuestas es decir ha aumentado en las
encuestas a punta de consignas sencillas
y de un trabajo magistral en redes
sociales hay que reconocérselo que a la
hora de materializarse ya en políticas
concretas pues genera la duda de cuál
será su agenda su agenda programática
para dar un solo ejemplo en su discurso
anti corrupción y reducción de gastos ha
propuesto entre otras cosas
prácticamente eliminar el servicio
exterior de colombia como una manera de
reducir los costos de la actividad
pública con lo cual a mí me genera la
duda ya que trabajo en temas
internacionales de cómo colombia
sostendrá una presencia robusta
internacional sino un servicio exterior
por ejemplo
claro teniendo además una diáspora
colombiana
muy grande de millones de colombianos
que han salido del país debido a la
guerra los temas económicos y hay una
población muy grande de colombianos en
eeuu en españa en el reino unido- en
otros países también de la región
eso sería significativo para la
representación de ellos ya me quedan
pocos minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero aprovechar que en mi panel de
invitadas son mujeres y quiero hablar de
la representación femenina en estos
comicios no hay candidatas a la
presidencia
femeninas ingrid betancourt se retiró
hace algunas semanas y se unió a uno de
los candidatos pero si vemos a tres
mujeres
siendo
vicepresidentas aspirando al papel de
vicepresidenta es que tan importante es
el vicepresidente en colombia que dice
de esta representación femenina y bueno
también que haya cuatro
afrodescendientes aspirando al cargo de
vicepresidente eso también muestra un
poco de madurez democrática tal vez en
colombia santiago algo de madurez
democrática algo de apertura e inclusión
para grupos étnicos y por supuesto para
la presencia de mujeres como fórmulas
vicepresidenciales
yo diría que es algo también de
estrategias de campaña en varios de los
candidatos recurrieron a esta fórmula de
complementar con mujeres o con personas
de grupos étnicos diferentes
hasta colombianos especialmente y esto
es parte también de las estrategias
electorales pero destacaría santiago que
las elecciones a congreso logramos un
aumento importante de la llegada de
mujeres a senado y cámara casi de 910
puntos porcentuales que nos colocó en la
media regional y que es importante para
el país importante para colombia
rápidamente debo finalizar el programa y
concluyó con una pregunta rápida
patricia hay una segunda vuelta y
quienes pasan a esa segunda vuelta a
modo de conclusión muy probablemente
tengamos la segunda vuelta difícilmente
alguno de los candidatos va a alcanzar
el 50 por ciento más uno que se requiere
para que no vaya nuestra vuelta
quienes pasan hoy petro ya es un
candidato seguro en segunda vuelta y el
siguiente candidato yo creería que puede
ser por él
porque el ascenso de rodolfo hernández
podemos alcanzar le para pasar darling
rápidamente segunda vuelta acción hoy
quienes pasan se me acaba el tiempo
segunda vuelta yo creo que sí y pasarán
probablemente los que indica mi colega
patricia perfecto muchísimas gracias a
las dos por haber estado con nosotros y
va a haber analizado este tema para la
audiencia de france 24 en américa
latina' ustedes sigan en sintonía de
france 24
[Música]